-One of my favorite
things, of course,
is sketches that are written
that do not make it to the show,
-Oh, yeah.
-And some of these ideas maybe
have not even been written.
-Yeah, that's true.
-Do you have some favorites?
-Even the ones that have been
written haven't really been
written.
They've been like really,
half thought out.
-What is
the Rosetta Stone sketch?
-This was when Donald Trump
hosted.
I pitched him an idea that he
weirdly didn't want to do,
where he was the spokesman
for Rosetta Stone Mexican.
[ Laughter ]
So he would teach you phrases
you could say to someone
who was Mexican, like,
"You're gonna build the wall."
-Oh, I see.
-No -- no, usted are.
You know, whatever.
-Usted are.
-What was heroin A.M.?
-[ Laughs ]
-That was non-drowsy heroin.
[ Laughter ]
It was from the makers
of cocaine P.M.
[ Laughter ]
And it was a sketch that was not
popular in middle America.
-Some sketches are just good
ideas and it's not even funny.
-Yeah, that's a great product.
-That's just a good product.
-Yeah.
-You want to take heroin,
but you also want to get some
stuff done.
-What was -- was it your idea
the origin of screw the pooch?
-Yeah. I wanted to do a sketch
about the first guy to ever say
the phrase "screwed the pooch"
because an intern one time
messed up a coffee order,
and I was like,
"hey, I didn't order this."
And he goes, "I'm sorry
about that, Che.
I really screwed the pooch
on that one."
And I said, "what was that?"
[ Laughter ]
And he goes,
"screwed the pooch.
It means I made a mistake."
And I was like "no, man,
it means, you had sex
with a dog."
[ Laughter ]
"And you should probably stop
saying that
in a workplace environment."
So I wanted to just dig
into that guy, because I'm sure
he probably had sex with a dog
one time and just kept
pretending that it was
a mistake that everybody else
makes.
-Yeah, that's like the coffee
thing. We all make mistakes.
-Oh, you messed up the coffee?
Now who has sex with dogs?
Still you, Gary! You're still
the only one that's done that.
-Half Viagra?
-Oh, yeah. That's a fun one.
-Well, we kept seeing
these ads -- I don't know
if you've seen them --
for single packs of Viagra.
Where it's like a weird husband,
and it's, like, "we're going on
a trip with my wife"
and he's like,
"oh, we'll pack one single
pack of Viagra."
He's like, "I want to have sex,
but I don't want to carry
the whole bottle."
-[ Laughs ] Right.
-You know, so on vacation,
you can be like,
"you get one shot."
But we wanted to do ads
for half-packs of Viagra.
And if you didn't want to have
sex, you just wanted to make it
look a little bigger.
[ Laughter ]
Like if you knew you were
going somewhere,
like you had a doctor's
appointment, you know?
-Or like a tailor or something.
You know --
You wanna...Got to use like,
a stadium urinal.
You want people to be...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-You know?
Whatever. I still say we should
have called it Viagra al dente.
[ Laughter ]
-First black guy to boo
Jackie Robinson?
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
First of all, it was February,
and I wanted
a black history sketch.
-Yep.
-And I was like,
"who was the first black guy to
boo Jackie Robinson
for a baseball play?"
There had to be one.
I mean, he -- I'm sure
he had an error before.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah. Censor said no.
-Really?
-Yeah, my favorite sketches are,
like, really racially charged.
-Yeah.
-Like Chris Hemsworth hosted,
and I wanted to do a sketch
where the Avengers save the day,
but in the process,
Thor accidentally kills
an unarmed black teenager.
[ Laughter ]
-He didn't think that was
on brand?
-Yeah, he said it wouldn't
help with tickets.
[ Laughter ]
-I think it would've
helped with tickets.
-I thought it would help
with tickets, too.
-You had a -- Was it
a CVS game show sketch?
-A game show that was set inside
of a CVS that was called
"Who Works Here?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one.
-Contestants had to buzz in
and try and decide is that
you know, an employee,
or a drifter in a red vest?
[ Laughter ]
-And then, this one you guys
should've done.
Cecilia Gimenez was a character
that Kate McKinnon played.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yes.
-And for the actual news story
when she first played him,
there was a painting
of Jesus, right?
-Yeah.
-...that someone repainted...
-And then, like, to retouch it,
and then it looked like
a howler monkey.
-Basically.
-It was, like, the worst
repainting job of all time.
-Yeah.
And then we did one I think
where she did
that Cristiano Ronaldo statue
that was in segment two.
-Yeah.
-Or the Lucy one -- it was like
a Lucille Ball where she looked
like the snake character
from "Beetlejuice."
[ Laughter ]
And this, someone talked about
'cause they saw --
I don't know if you guys saw
the animatronic Trump
at Disney World or something...
-Frightening.
-...where she was the one who
designed that.
It basically looked like
a way worse Jon Voight.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Melty Voight.
So what is the pressure like?
Obviously, every week on "SNL,"
there is a certain amount
of pressure.
You guys have one
of the all-time greats,
Will Ferrell, this week.
-Yeah.
Some would say, oh, my God,
cruise control,
but you have to feel pressure.
-Yeah. You do, you feel a lot
of pressure 'cause everyone
already knows he's good.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
So if it's not good,
it's our fault.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
We're the ones that's
the problem, so, yeah,
it's a lot of pressure.
Hopefully Will can step up
to it.
[ Laughter ]
Carry us through
with a cowbell, too.
-Well, I especially am grateful
you guys came here tonight
because pretty much you're gonna
leave here and you're gonna go
right upstairs...
-Yeah.
-...and write through the night.
I can't wait for Saturday.
It's always such a pleasure
to see both of you.
-Thank you for having us.
-And "Update" has been
so fantastic this year.
Keep up the great work.
-Ah, thank you, man.
-Congratulations
on the Globes, too.
You were fantastic
hosting the Globes.
-Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wonderful.
-Jost -- Jost sent me jokes for
the Globes, which was very nice,
and like a day before
the Globes, you had an idea.
-Oh, yeah.
-It was unproduceable.
-Yeah, I wanted Andy Samberg
to play the creature
from "The Shape of Water."
[ Laughter ]
And that he was in the audience
and he was falling in love
with Seth as the show went on.
And the second time you saw him,
he was in a bathtub on stage
asking Seth to get in
the bathtub.
[ Laughter ]
-And it was great 'cause it
was written like someone who had
never been in show business.
-Yes.
That's how I try to approach
every idea.
[ Laughter ]
You had the good sense to do
like, good, "smart stuff."
-No, no, no, I -- but I did like
the idea of like, just
constantly, like,
in the middle of, like,
a speech.
Like Oprah giving her speech,
Andy being like,
"I need water!"
[ Laughter ]
I think that was what
the evening needed.
-You definitely should have
booed Oprah.
That would've been the best.
[ Laughter ]
-Like, what?
-Get Seth back out!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you guys so much
for being here.